tenemos la función g de x que es igual a
2 entre x a la 3 -1 entre x al cuadrado
y lo que quiero que hagamos en este
vídeo es encontrar la derivada de g lo
que quiero que encontremos que prima de
x pero también quiero encontrar cuánto
vale esta función
evaluada en 2 si es que queremos
encontrar que prima en 2 a cuánto es
igual o sea que quiero saber cuál es la
pendiente de la recta tangente a la
función g cuando x es igual a 2 y como
siempre pone pausa este vídeo e intenta
resolverlo por tu cuenta vamos a
resolverlo paso por paso como siempre
pero primero intenta hacerlo sin ver
cómo lo hago yo aunque bueno podría
darte unas cuantas pistas lo único que
necesitas es aplicar la regla de las
potencias utilizar un poco las
propiedades de los exponentes
y las propiedades básicas de las
derivadas pero bueno ahora sí espero que
ya lo hayas intentado vamos a hacerlo
paso por paso y voy a empezar
reescribiendo esta función
de x lo podemos escribir de esta otra
forma ok el primer término 2 entre x a
la 3
lo podemos escribir como 2 por equis
elevado a la potencia menos 3 porque
sabemos que uno entre x a la n es igual
a x a la menos n
así es que aquí simplemente reescribir
este término y ahora tal vez ya sabes
cómo vamos a utilizar la regla de las
potencias y luego estamos restando el
siguiente término que es 1 / x al
cuadrado y esto se puede escribir como x
elevado a la menos 2 y ahora podemos
sacar la derivada de todo podemos sacar
la derivada con respecto de x de g
y la derivada con respecto de x de todo
esto ahora
la derivada con respecto de x deje de x
prima de equis y ahora vamos a derivar
esta expresión de acá estamos sacando la
derivada con respecto a x de este
término y aquí pues simplemente vamos a
usar la regla de las potencias tomamos
el exponente lo multiplicamos por el
coeficiente aquí adelante vamos a
escribir eso de una vez
tenemos 2 x menos 3
x y ahora tenemos que decrecer el
exponente pero tenemos que hacerlo con
mucho cuidado porque nuestro cerebro
muchas veces dice hay menos tres menos
uno
eso es menos 2 pero no es así recuerda
estamos yendo hacia abajo si tenemos
menos 3 y restamos 1 si tenemos menos 3
y restamos 1 esto nos da menos 4
- 4 tenemos x elevado a la potencia
menos 4 la derivada de este término
verde aqua
2 x menos 3 x x a la menos 4 pero eso lo
podemos escribir como menos 6 x x a la
menos 4 y luego menos y vamos a hacer
exactamente lo mismo con el término azul
tomamos el menos dos lo multiplicamos
por el coeficiente que está
implícitamente aquí siempre estamos
multiplicando implícitamente por un 1
entonces tenemos menos 2 por 1 aquí está
el menos dos y multiplicamos por x
elevado a cuál potencia
bueno pues cuanto es menos dos menos uno
pues es menos tres tenemos x elevado a
la potencia menos 3
así es que podemos escribir todo esto de
aquí como que prima de x igual a menos 6
por x a la menos 4 y luego por acá
estamos restando un número con un signo
negativo y menos pro menos nos da más
así
que estos 2 - se cancelan y nos queda
más 2 por equis a la menos 3 y listo ya
terminamos con la primera parte ya
encontramos que prima de x ahora vamos
con la siguiente parte que es evaluar a
la derivada de g
cuando x es igual a 2 lo que queremos es
encontrar que prima de 2 y esto es igual
a menos 6 por 2 a la menos 4 menos seis
por dos a la menos cuatro más dos por
dos a la menos tres y esto a que es
igual
bueno pues es igual a menos 6 entre 2 a
la 4 + 2 entre 2 a la 3 lo cual a su vez
es igual a menos 6 entre 2 a la 4 es 16
2 entre 2 a la 3 es 8 bueno pero ahora
estaría bien simplificar esto no ponerlo
con un denominador común por ejemplo
aquí esto lo podría escribir como un
cuarto pero a la hora de sacar el común
denominador regresaríamos a lo que
tenemos pero este aunque no lo podemos
escribir como cuartos si lo podemos
escribir como octavos menos seis
dieciseisavos son menos tres octavos y
menos tres octavos más dos octavos es
igual a menos un octavo y listo
entonces la pendiente de la recta
tangente a la función g
cuando x es igual a 2 cuando nos paramos
en el punto x igualados la pendiente de
la recta tangente es menos un octavo